The Meg has swum up from the murky depths
to chomp on theater screens everywhere after
a long voyage out of prehistory.
Here's a quick look at how the creature feature
came together, how it ends, and why there
might be a follow-up.
Massive spoilers ahead!
Based on Steve Alten's 1997 book Meg: A Novel
of Deep Terror, The Meg has been 20 years
in the making, splashing fruitlessly in development
hell at multiple studios.
At various stages, Guillermo del Toro, Jan
de Bont, and Eli Roth were attached to direct
before National Treasure's Jon Turteltaub
took the helm and steered the thriller to
fruition as an American-Chinese co-production.
Even then, it wasn't exactly smooth sailing,
as shifting ratings concerns kept the vision
for the project in flux.
At the heart of the story is rescue diver
Jonas Taylor, played by Jason Statham, who
joins a group of scientists, including his
ex-wife, on a mission to take down a deadly,
supposedly extinct, 75-foot-long Megalodon
shark.
As Statham puts it, it's ...
"... a fun, shark movie that's like, the ultimate
popcorn movie, a bit of fun that doesn't take
itself too seriously."
Naturally, The Meg concludes with an escalating
series of confrontations against the prehistoric
beast, including one in which the audience
is briefly led to believe the shark has been
felled with poison.
Alas, the wrong ocean carnivore was killed,
and after a grenade attack launched from a
helicopter also fails, it falls to our hero
Jonas to save a crowded Chinese beach.
Busting out of his damaged submersible, he
scratches the beast to make it bleed and attract
other sharks, who devour the Meg, finally
killing it.
While this particular Megalodon definitely
won't be coming back, there is hope for a
franchise featuring the movie's human characters,
likely based on the original novel's many
follow-ups.
The Meg's secret weapon just might be the
chemistry between its leads.
Jason Statham and Li Bingbing, playing oceanographer
Suyin Zhang, are a likable pair whose romance
blossoms in the face of shark terror.
Seeing their relationship continue to bloom
while staring down the maw of another deep-sea
terror could make for a perfectly charming
follow-up.
Then there's "engineering genius" Jaxx Herd,
played by up-and-coming Australian actress
Ruby Rose.
The Meg is one of Rose's biggest screen roles
yet, after a streak that includes appearances
in Orange Is the New Black, xXx: The Return
of Xander Cage, and John Wick Chapter 2.
Just before the release of The Meg, Rose was
announced to be playing Batwoman in the CW's
DC Universe, with the potential for a show
of her very own on the horizon.
"Yeah, that was probably the most grueling
audition process."
With a star rising as rapidly as Ruby Rose's,
the idea of Jaxx returning in a Meg sequel
would likely be very appealing.
But there isn't really any precedence for
studios producing quality shark-attack-based
sequels, so this is uncharted territory.
The original Jaws is an undisputed masterpiece
that changed the face of summer blockbusters
forever.
But taken together, Jaws 2, Jaws 3-D, and
Jaws: The Revenge provide one of cinema history's
most striking examples of the Law of Diminishing
Returns.
Plus, we're about to get a sixth Sharknado.
So if The Meg gets a sequel, and it's at all
well-received, it would be a first.
The reviews for The Meg are decidedly mixed,
but early box office projections predict it
could surpass all financial expectations,
so only time will tell if another journey
to the bottom of the sea is in Jason Statham's
future.